John Legend opens up about he and wife
Chrissy Teigen fertility struggles and
admits it only made their marriage
stronger for us it's like it's really
normal I'm not sure I'd be able to share
our lives with them in a new interview
with Cosmopolitan John gets candid about
trying to get pregnant with the couple's
first child telling the mad quote going
through that together strengthens your
bond because if you can make it through
having a child you know you can make it
through anything John and Chrissy have
been open about conceiving their
daughter Luna using in vitro treatments
and the pair is hopeful the same process
can help them conceive baby number two
quote IVF brought us Luna and hopefully
it will bring us a few more awesome kids
to the olivey singer also reacted to
Chrissy's commitment to cut back on
drinking while he's a supportive husband
38 year old John emphasizes he's not the
perfect spouse adding whenever she sets
her mind to anything I always tell her I
want to support you and help you do it
I'm a lucky man
[Music]